what kind of backing or not packing as I
think I know the answer already are you
getting from your University because
they've done some kind of shady stuff
with you as well right
yeah well after I released these videos
so the first video question bill c16 and
similar provincial legislation and I
said in the video that making the video
was now probably illegal so we've come
to the point where even questioning the
damn legislation in Canada has become a
new legal act then I made another video
about the human resources departments
decision to make anti racism and antique
bias training mandatory for their staff
and a third one about the PC game and
within a week that that that initiated
two demonstrations at the university
campus and the second one list was a
free speech rally which I didn't
organize but spoke at and that was the
one where the journalist Lorne Southern
was assaulted by a professional activist
and and and how and was second and by
another who immediately lied about what
she had seen have to become infamous on
on YouTube um the university sent me a
warning letter on October 3rd that was a
week after I made the videos accusing me
of producing saying that they had
received many letters from the
university community stating that I was
making an unsafe environment and and
enumerated a variety of threats that had
been put forth against trans people on
on social media hypothetically you know
right without and and so they warned me
and told me to stop repeating my
statement that I wouldn't use these
these gender-neutral pronouns the reason
they did that was because they reviewed
the policies and concluded the same
thing I concluded which was that what I
was doing was illegal and you see the
legislation is written and this is a
real key element of it this is something
really quite wonderful if you're an
employer in in Ontario now you are as
responsible for your employees acts of
speaking as they are and you're
responsible for the consequences of
their speech acts whether they're
intentional or unintentional and whether
or not a complain
to be made so you're responsible for
whatever your employees say even if you
don't know about it even if no one
complains even if it was accidental man
I mean there's there's so much here so a
let's just pause for a second because it
warrants to mention that you are a
tenured professor which means that they
they can't fire you just for no reason I
think to even is it even ever possible
to fire tenured professor take on you
can do it the way there's they're there
they're planning they're planning at
least to open that up as a possibility
um the way you do that is the same way
you discipline any employee you send
them a warning letter outlining what
they're doing wrong and telling them to
stop doing it oh and when they wrote the
first letter they mischaracterize what I
said quite badly and I took I know I
challenged come on out and told them
that they should go and rewrite the
letter and do it properly if they were
going to come after me but they refused
my my refusal and so I kept the letter
and I got another letter on the 18th and
it was a real masterpiece of doublespeak
because they repeated their their claims
that they had received you know many
many letters which I'm sure they had
from from people within the university
but I knew at that point that they'd all
have already also received at least five
hundred letters from people supporting
me because I was CCD on the letters as
well as a petition that was signed by
ten thousand people they never even
mentioned that and they said that I had
to stop they told me I had to bring my
behavior in line with university policy
and stop repeating the the claim that I
wouldn't use gender-neutral pronouns and
one of the things that was really absurd
about that is so I was accused of
violating University policy but their
own policy drafted in 1992 which is a
their policy on freedom of speech states
outright that at the university freedom
of speech is the highest value and the
professor's not only have a the right
but the obligation to engage in the
criticism criticism of the university on
society at large so it was hypocritical
to the enth degree and then even we're
having a debate at 9:30 in the morning
on Saturday it's going to be live cast
on my youtube channel Jordan Peterson
videos the university I proposed that
the university hold a debate about these
issues and they actually agree although
they told me and this really put my tail
in the knot because I didn't know what
to do about it
they told me that they'd go ahead with
the debate
but then I couldn't repeat my insistence
that I wouldn't use gender-neutral
pronouns in the free speech debate right
so let's just get this straight they
allowed you to go ahead and do this okay
that sounds good but then the condition
was that you actually could not repeat
the very things that got this whole mess
going in the first yeah yeah so so I
came home after that I wasn't sure what
to do because I thought well first of
all it took me a while just to Reese it
was like being in a deli painting it's
so surreal I thought oh this is
interesting we're gonna have a free
speech debate with the restriction on
free speech implicit in the debate so I
thought I don't know what the hell to do
about this so I called a few theaters
and I because I thought well to hell
with it I'll just I'll just do this by
myself but then and I talked to my
family my parents were visiting and I
talked to my son and my and my wife we
talked about this a lot and I wrote the
university a letter and I said look I'm
not sure I can do this this is this is
absurd here's a better idea here's a
better idea you guys are making a
mistake you're supporting the wrong
horse you're backing the wrong horse so
why don't you do this instead why don't
you come out in favor of my right to
freedom of speech regardless of whether
you agree with me put your legal
department behind protecting me um
instead of threatening me essentially
with the loss of my job which is what
they're what they're fundamentally doing
and we'll fight this all the way to the
Supreme Court and so I went and talked
to the Dean who helped arrange the
debate and he said there's no way the
university will do that and so I made
another video saying all that and posted
it online I guess about 60,000 people
watched that but I didn't I decided to
go ahead with the debate and there were
two reasons for that one was I know that
it's very difficult for anything to
happen without it being imperfect and
often the price you pay for moving ahead
with something is to accept its
imperfections like the snake in the
Garden of Eden you know there's always a
snake in the damn garden and so I
thought this was the snake and I thought
well I thought it would be better to
have the debate under university
auspices then for me to go alone partly
because the university should be hosting
this debate and partly because I also
couldn't see this was a secondary
concern but I also couldn't see any way
out of the conundrum where I didn't lose
so if I refuse the debate then what
would have happened was the university
would have said well we offered in good
faith and Peterson rejected it and all
the people that I would have
hypothetically debate would have said oh
well he just had an excuse and you know
and he just took whatever excuse was was
open to him so that he didn't have to
face us so so anyways for better or
worse the debates on at 9:30 in the
morning on Saturday so and I think
tickets go on sale tomorrow but it will
be live cast yeah all right well I'll be
sure to promote that absolutely I'm
curious what kind of support were not
supported you got another academic it
sounds like University of Toronto is not
really on board what you're doing but
what about academics Oh none nothing
none to speak up now the Society for
academic freedom in Halifax came out and
supported me and they're a decent
organization although they don't really
have any teeth but that's not their
fault I mean they're doing their best
but um the silence from my faculty
colleagues apart from the 200 who wrote
a letter denouncing me fail and and
didn't have enough courage to mention
that it was actually me they were
denouncing even though when they sent
the letter to the varsity which is the
University of Toronto newspaper they
said it was about me which I thought was
really funny wait so so when they write
a letter about you you know how many of
them do you think actually believe the
content of what they're saying like
really believe that you should be
silenced versus that the inmates are
sort of running the asylum at colleges
now and they're that these other
professors are really just protecting
their own ass because they don't want
the mob to come after them I'm not
saying I think that's any better by the
way I wouldn't no no no I wouldn't say
that the people who denounced me did it
to protect themselves although there
would have been an element of that but
certainly many of the people who are
remaining silent are doing that to
protect themselves I mean I had a
colleague tell me it was actually one of
the reasons I made the video I had a
colleague say who's you know being on
the receiving end of some political
correctness he said well I won't do
anything
because the cost to me would be near
infinite and the social consequences
would be zero and that but that's always
how these situations work out and that's
why people remain silent and and
remaining silent is the worst thing that
you you abdicate your you abdicate your
privileges as a citizen when you remain
silent you no longer deserve to partake
of the of the freedoms of a citizen but
people will give up their their their
right to they'll give up the rights at
the drop of a hat and the silence from
my faculty colleagues as being
absolutely deafening yeah and you know
it's very ugly
well it's no different than I mean I
don't like to make this comparison but
there was no courage on the part of the
intellectuals when the Soviets started
to dismantle universities there was no
courage among the academics when the
Nazis started to do the same thing in
the 1930s and it's the same process I
mean I'm not trying to draw a direct
equivalent but it's the same process it
requires almost no pressure to
intimidate people into silence but
that's because people aren't afraid
enough you know people have been asking
me how I can tolerate the stress it's
like first of all compared to real
stress a sick child that's stressful
this is a political argument that what's
on a line is my job like that's that's
not that's not a tragedy it sucks and
it's stressful but I mean compared to
genuine stress it's nothing but but
compared to the stress that I would be
under if I agreed to use this language
see for me the real issue for me
personally is that I believe that these
made-up gender-neutral pronouns our
pirate are part of the radical dialectic
of the PC authoritarian left I think
they're carefully crafted terms I think
they have the intent behind them and
they're part and parcel of an ideology
and I dread and despise that ideology to
the bottom of my soul and there's not a
chance I'm going to use those words
because I would literally destroy my
integrity and there I'm not doing that
I'd rather
I'd rather I can't think of anything
that would be worse for me than that
would break me yeah and you know I love
that passion and it's so obvious how
personal this excuse me how personal
this is to you I'm curious what do you
think is it about you that is willing to
put this I I get what you're saying it
would hurt you to your core but I just
mean like what about your maybe four
million years or something that you're
the one that's putting yourself on the
line for this and I know there are a
couple of there you know there's my
friend GAD sad who I know you got to use
an academia in Canada I'm talking about
this stuff and I know I have a few
allies in the United States really
protecting free speech and then they're
growing by the way which is why so many
people wanted me to talk to you but what
do you think really is it about you that
makes you say okay we'll put my ass on
the line for this well I wrote a book in
nineteen I published a book in 1999
called maps of meaning and the course
lectures about that are on my video
channel and I wrote Maps a meeting
because I was absolutely obsessed with
what had happened in in Nazi Germany and
in the Soviet Union and and I mean I
really truly mean obsessed I spent
virtually every waking second for 15
years thinking about nothing else than
that and read very very very widely I
read I read all of Carl Jung I read more
well and Huxley and Solzhenitsyn and a
slew of books on neurobiology and all
the great clinical psychologists and a
huge chunk of political economy and like
I read a very very vast amount of
psychological and political literature
and I synthesized this over the course
of $15,000 that's how long it took me to
write that book and the reason I did it
was because I was trying to understand
the relationship between belief and
emotion and motivation and more
specifically or I'll tell you a story
here's what I was trying to understand
right
so one of the tricks that the guards
used to pull in Osh wits was that when
the prisoners were or the detainees were
dumped off the rail cars where they'd be
packed in like cheap worse than sheep
and where many of them died of
suffocation and dehydration and
overheating when they were dumped off at
the camp
and they were ruined by then already
because you know they'd be ripped away
from their families and had their lives
destroyed and but that wasn't good
enough for the our sewage guards and one
of the tricks they used to pull on them
was they'd have that the inmates pick up
a hundred pound sack of web salt and
carry it from one side of the compound
to the other and then back and so it
said on the horse which gates work will
make you free which was a which was a
joke a black black joke a joke from the
depths of hell that like mutual assured
destruction the same kind of humor and I
was very interested in I thought oh okay
a nosh wits guard an ostrich guard could
take someone who is already ruined he'd
lost their family was suffering
dreadfully and then make them do
something effortful and terrible because
these camps were paid to carry that the
sack of salt from one side that's a city
these were cities these weren't like
little prisons and it was to demonstrate
to the person their absolute abject
humiliation and to deprive them of any
sense of accomplishment whatsoever that
they might extract from their labor okay
so I was interested in that but I was
interested in why a human being would do
that to another human being but I was
interested in that in a very particular
way because you see the people in Oz
wigs who were the guards they were
ordinary people and that meant that
ordinary people can do that and that
meant I could do it and so I wanted to
figure out just exactly what that meant
and so I didn't figure out what that
meant you know young said that the human
shadow stretches all the way down to
hell and that's exactly right
it's really directly true and so I
realized that when I was writing maps of
meaning after some experiences I had
also working I worked I worked visited
is more the accurate term but I worked
for this strange psychologist in
Edmonton who was the prison psychologist
had the Edmonton maximum security prison
and I went out there a few times and
observed the convicts and started
thinking about what motivated them to
and you know I had a revelation not long
after that about about atrocity and the
revelation was because I didn't think I
was capable of doing such a thing but I
thought about it a long time and I
realized I was bloody fully capable of
it and so then I start
how's load given the human capacity to
do that and maybe even to revel in it
maybe even to enjoy it um what can
possibly be done and and you know people
often perform that sort of atrocity
under the guise of ideological
commitment well I'm persecuting the Jews
because I'm actually a really good guy
here's what I want here's my good
intentions right you know here's my good
intentions and they just happen to be
collateral damage and so it's actually
moral and ethical than I'm doing this
but really they're they're just just
taking the opportunity to to act out
their their deep deep hatred of being
and hatred of reality and and and
contempt for Humanity well I wrote maps
of meaning in an attempt to understand
that motivation and to determine what
people could do so that if the
opportunity arose once again each
individual would not choose to be an
ostrich camp guard so what do you think
and I would welcome everyone we'll put
the link link yeah what do you think is
the best way to extricate yourself from
that type of thinking what's the best
way to insulate yourself well so that
when the day comes and you are faced
with some horrific choice that you don't
jump in with the collective and you know
the Nazi guards of course yep the phrase
that the hell he said was well I was
just following orders but organized
orders allowed them to do you know
absolutely horrific things so what can
we all do to make sure that as the
choices come to us whatever they may be
that we don't do the horrible game well
a lot of people have thought through
this you know Viktor Frankl wrote man's
search for meaning he came to the to a
particular conclusion and so did so did
Dostoevsky so did Alexander Solzhenitsyn
so did václav havel who was the the
dissident Czech dissident who eventually
became president they all said the same
thing those systems exist because people
lie and the way you fight them is you
don't lie you don't lie about anything
ever and so that's what you do and you
think well how can that make a
difference while Solzhenitsyn said
Solzhenitsyn wrote the Gulag Archipelago
in the 1970s and he detailed the
transformation of the Marxist
philosophical doctrine
into the murderous legislation that
killed perhaps 50 million people in the
Soviet Union between 1919 and 1959 said
the entire society was pervaded by lies
but one-third of the people were
government informers you could never say
anything that that that you believe to
be true and it starts by people doesn't
start by people directly lying in start
starts by people muffling themselves
because there are certain things you can
no longer say and you you demolish your
character you weaken your character but
through sins of omission and you get
weak and as soon as you're weak people
can manipulate you like mad so the way
you fight back against totalitarianism
is that you tell the truth and you act
out the truth your truth you know and
you you you subject yourself to
correction from other people because the
truth truth is a process right it's a
process of successive approximation and
that's far more powerful than anything
else you could do you know it's
interesting of course do you think
people the average person is actually
starving for truth really I don't mean
like human truth of the origins of the
universe although many of us are but I
mean just simple truths about how our
politicians operate how our lives
operate our day to day truths because I
find all the time people will email me
and say you know it's so great what
you're doing in free speech it's up and
oh and I'm my response to everybody is I
don't think I'm doing anything that
great other than telling the truth the
way I see it I'm trying to use logic and
reason and to talk to people I find
interesting to learn and expand my
knowledge and that's my quest for truth
and I think people have been so dumbed
down that the that they're almost afraid
of finding it because the system has
just rewarded idiocy in a way yeah well
people you know it says in the New
Testament that man does not live by
bread alone and and that's a technical
commentary on the utility of the truth
the truth is the truth is you can say
spiritual food and and I use that
metaphor purposefully you you you live
on information your your cognitive
apparatus you live on information and it
in information you transform into it you
transform information into the
tools you use to operate within the
world and if your tools are faulty then
your life will be terrible if you're if
you're fanned on a diet of deceit then
you'll be you'll be pathological in
everything you do and the world will
kick back at you extraordinarily hard
the first thing it will do is deprive
you of any sense of meaning and then
it'll make you bitter and then it will
make you resentful and then it'll make
you murderous and then it'll make you
Jenna Seidel that's the developmental
pathway you know in those kids the
people who shoot up the high schools
they've already hit murderers they're
they're like there and I on the way to
Genesis Jonas Idol and part of the
reason is is that a life that's
characterized by nothing but deceit has
no positive meaning in it but plenty of
suffering because you can lie you can
lie to yourself and you can lie to other
people but the probability that that's
that you're going to be able to talk
yourself out of your terror and pain is
zero and as far as I can tell truth is
the only genuine antidote to suffering
because getting rid of suffering that
isn't going to happen the only thing you
can do is live in a manner that enables
you to withstand suffering without
becoming corrupt and that means that you
you live by the truth and no matter what
and then there's a there's a coda that
goes along with that which is something
that took me decades to understand is
that Kierkegaard talked about this
affair that when he talked about the
leap of faith necessary for true
religious belief said telling the truth
is a it's a it's a it's a gamble on the
benevolence of being so the idea is well
you tell the truth you don't manipulate
the world to make it give you what you
want you just say what you try to
articulate yourself and articulate the
manner of your being is clearly and
comprehensively as possible and then you
see what happens and you decide this is
the act of faith you decide that no
matter what happens if you tell the
truth that that's the best possible
outcome and the thing is is that at the
bottom of your being there's always a
decision that has to be made about how
you're going to interact in the world
because you have free choice whatever
that means you've seen to have it and
and so you have to make a decision about
about how it is that you're going to act
in the world and and you act in truth if
you can and that's the that's the
pathway out of out of the kind of misery
that makes people bitter and and and and
and far worse than bitter yeah well it's
incredibly obvious to me that you're
living in your truth and because you're
doing that you're waking up a lot of
other people which is why so many people
wanted me to wanted me to talk to you so
what what do you think this will be the
final question what do you think is the
best way to if you for all the people
that are watching this right now to
understand this that here you that
understand the passion that want to live
that way to how can they get involved in
this process is it's simply just doing
oh I can tell ya I can tell you all
right so most of your viewers will have
watched Pinocchio probably the scene in
Pinocchio where Geppetto wishes on a
star right and what it means is he lifts
up his eyes beyond the horizon to
something transcendent to something
ultimate because that's what a star is
it's part of the of the Eternity of the
night sky and so he lifts his eyes up
above his daily concerns and he says
what I want what what I want more than
anything else is that my creation will
become a genuine individual right it's
it's a heroic gesture because it's so
unlikely and that catalyzes the puppets
transformation into a real being and we
start as puppets and so the trick is to
get rid of your goddamn strings and you
remember in Pinocchio he faces a lot of
temptations one is to be a liar the
other is to be a neurotic victim that's
how he ends up in Pleasure Island where
he just about gets sold into the salt
mines turns into a brain jack house and
sold to the salt mines because it's run
by authoritarians well okay so what you
do is you lift up your eyes and you say
look I would like being to progress in
the best possible manner and that's best
for me best for my family best for
society maybe best for the world
simultaneously I would like to
whatever that is that's what I want you
commit to that then you tell the truth
and then you can tell if you're telling
the truth you can tell it
physiologically and so this is something
to learn you watch what you say and you
will find out that some things you say
make you come apart they make you fall
apart they and you can feel it it's
physiologically it's centered in your
it's centered in your solar plexus it's
a feeling of chaotic weakness and
dissolution it's a sense of self
betrayal and then if you tell the truth
that pulls you together and strengthens
you and so you can learn to feel when
your words are accurately articulating
yourself and then you practice that and
that makes you into the sort of person
that won't be an r6 guard that won't
play ideological games that won't
sacrifice other people to their
expedience and that's what you have to
do it spits them it's and that's really
the core idea at Western civilization is
to build yourself into a forthright
individual who's capable of of telling
the truth and and capable of marrying
the responsibilities of citizenry and
that's what people have to do well
Jordan you eloquently and passionately
spoke about so many of the things that I
care about and so many other things that
I've tried to live my life for and
you've also partly renewed my spirit too
cute to keep doing those things and I
think you've given a little bit of that
star to a lot of the people that we're
wondering where the hell is everybody on
this so you absolutely have an ally in
me and I hope next time you come to the
states we can do this in person and and
if there's anything I can do for you
please let me know and your videos are
at youtube.com slash Jordan Peterson
videos and and as you said Saturday are
you are you live streaming on Saturday
is that reliance routing I live Street
yeah okay well I'll be sure to tweet
that out and thank you it was a pleasure
to talk to you and good luck I have a
feeling our site is coming around so I
hope it's a long fight but we're in it
yeah we're in it all right all right
thank you so much
you